[Music]
Why do the chosen and Jonathan Roomie,
the man portraying Jesus for millions,
have so many ties to the Freemasons,
Jesuits, and Knights Templars?
coincidence or carefully orchestrated
deception? Because the more we dig, the
more the evidence keeps stacking up. If
these secret societies are involved, the
real question is why? Why this show? Why
this actor? And more importantly, what
is their endgame? I poured over
interviews, articles, historical
records, hidden symbols, and even
ancient secret society documents. What I
found, it will change your understanding
of Protestant Christianity to the
[Music]
core. Because what if Jonathan Roomie
wasn't just cast in The Chosen? What if
he was placed there?
Hey everybody, real quick. So in this
episode, we are going to discuss a
specific religious entity. And I want to
preface this that in no way, no means
are we attacking any individual, any
person that wholeheartedly, genuinely is
part of this religious entity and is
seeking out the truth. That's not our
aim. That's not our goal. We have high
regard and respect for anybody being
part of that. We are not attacking the
people. We are just discussing the
system as it is described in Bible
prophecy and end time prophecy. Okay,
let's dive in.
[Music]
I was a diehard fan of The Chosen. I
watched all three seasons, some episodes
five times over, and I I even considered
buying merch to, you know, show my
support. But then Little Light Studios,
the channel you're seeing this
documentary on, released their former
documentary about The Chosen. At the
time, I didn't work for them yet, so I
had no bias. And, you know, I ignored
it. People shared their concerns with
me, but I dismissed it because I thought
it was a beautiful depiction of Jesus
and I thought, how can that possibly be
dangerous? And then I joined Little
Light Studios and obviously there was
this documentary. I thought, if I
claimed to love Jesus and love truth,
then how could I refuse to look at both
sides? How could I ignore the Holy
Spirit's prompings just because I didn't
want to be wrong? And so I watched it.
And that moment I watched it was the
moment that I never watched The Chosen
again. Now I'm making another
documentary about The Chosen. But this
time we're looking at something even
deeper. Jonathan Roomie, secret
societies, and how it all connects to
prophecy and Christ's soon return. But
deception is great, but Christ is
greater. In a previous documentary about
the chosen, we showed you a pretty
startling clip where Jonathan Roomie
openly admits to being a knight's
Templar. If you haven't seen it yet,
take a look. I'm wearing a mantle and a
cross with a little crown on it. Um, a
knight's cross. Uh, 5 years ago, I was
uh kneded by the order, the solemn
uh sovereign military order of the
temple of Jerusalem. I lost my mind
there for a second. Um, essentially the
Knights Templar, which is what that is.
If you don't know who the Knights
Templar is, look at the structure of
Freemasonry. The Knight's Templar is
literally the top step. It is on par
with a 33rd degree Freemason. In fact,
you can't get any higher, well, at least
any higher than they tell us you can get
than a 33rd degree Freemason or a
Knights Templar. On his Instagram, which
was dated in 2020, it says, "It was an
epic inaugural event, and on behalf of
my fellow Templar brothers and sisters,
we are so grateful to have been a part
of it. The guy who is stamping Jesus in
everybody's mind is literally on par
with the 33rd degree Freemason. Now,
here's where things get even more
concerning. Jonathan Roomie isn't just
claiming to be a Knights Templar. That
title alone puts him on the same level
as a 33rd degree Freemason, as we
mentioned in the other documentary. But
it doesn't stop there. Look at how much
he's using skull imagery. You've seen
it, right? Like the rings he's wearing.
He's wearing the clothing. He's got all
of the symbols. So, what does that all
mean? Let listen to this clip from
Jonathan Rooney where he explains it
himself.
comes from a very deeply felt Catholic
Christian
tradition about
mortality and the need to recognize our
mortality and to cultivate a deeper
sense of holiness in our lives today
because tomorrow is not guaranteed.
That's in a nutshell what this is.
Momento mori. Remember, you will die. We
will all die. It's just a part of life.
On the surface level, this seems like a
very honorable thing to do, right? Like
we should remember that we're going to
die someday and we should remember to
live our lives to the glory of God every
day because someday might be our last
day. But in this momento mory tradition,
Jonathan Rooney is not alone. There's
other Catholics like Father Mike
Schmidz, um, Sister Terresa Alata Noble,
Bishop Robert Baron, and others that all
promote this thing of
momentomory. So, let's talk about Bishop
Robert Baron. His Jesuit ties run deep.
In this biography that um Matthew Leing
writes about him, he highlights Baron's
admiration for Jesuit priest Pike Tower
the Chardin and Koner whom Baron says to
have been hugely influenced by his
ministry word and fire is also filled
with a ton of content promoting Ignatius
of Lyola and Ignatian spirituality.
Ignatius of Lyola being the founder of
the Jesuits. But momentum isn't just
Catholic. The Freemasons also claim it.
Listen to this from the Oriental Lodge
number 33 on their website. One of the
themes that Freemasonry emphasizes is
momento mori, which means remember that
you will die. Isn't that the same thing
that Jonathan Roomie said? So, let's
pause and connect the dots here.
Catholics and Jesuits teach momento
mori. Freemasons claim momento mory is
theirs. And Jonathan Roomie, a Catholic
actor who admits to being a Knights
Templar, is pushing it too. So why do
the Jesuits, Freemasons, and Knights
Templars all promote the same concept?
Let's go straight to the writings of
Albert Pike, a 33rd degree
Freemason and sovereign Grand Commander
of the Scottish Wright's Southern
Jurisdiction. I have right here in front
of me this book morals and dogma of
freemasonry. Basically this is their
religion. This is where they say this is
what they believe. Now in chapter 17
Pike writes the Templars or poor fellow
soldiery of the holy house of the temple
intended to be rebuilt took as their
models in the Bible the warrior masons
of Zorobil who worked holding the sword
in one hand and the trowel in the other.
Therefore, it was that the sword and the
trowel were the insignia of the Templars
who subsequently concealed themselves
under the name of brethren masons. The
name Frey Mason in the French was
corrupted in English into Freemasons.
So, Pike isn't just making an off-hand
remark here. He's drawing a direct
connection between the Knights Templars
and the origins of Freemasonry.
And in chapter 30, he takes it even
further, revealing what happened just
before Jacques de Mole, the last
grandmaster of the Templars, was
executed. The Templars were gravely
accused of spitting upon Christ and
denying God at their receptions, of
gross obscenities, conversations with
female devils, and the worship of a
monstrous idol. The end of the drama is
wellknown and how Jacqu de Mulai and his
fellows perished in the flames. But
before his execution, the chief of the
doomed order organized and instituted
what afterward came to be called the
occult. Hermetic or Scottish masonry. In
the gloom of his prison, the Grandmaster
created four metropolitan lodges at
Naples for the east, at Edinburg for the
west, at Stockholm for the north, and at
Paris for the south. The initials of his
name, JBM, found in the same order in
the first three degrees, are but one of
the many internal and cogent proofs that
such was the origin of modern
Freemasonry. I've also got a Masonic
Bible here. When you open it up, there
is a diagram in it with the plan of the
order of Freemasonry.
Right here in the structure of
Freemasonry, you can see the Knights
Templar and their symbol. Now, history
tells us that the Pope Clement V
officially dissolved the Knights
Templars of
1312. But the question is, did they
truly vanish or did they simply rebrand
morphing into Freemasonry? Just as Pike,
one of Freemasonry's highest
authorities, admits, "The order
disappeared at once. Its estates and
wealth were confiscated, and it seemed
to have ceased to exist. Nevertheless,
it lived under other names and governed
by unknown chiefs, revealing itself only
to those who, in passing through a
series of degrees, had proven themselves
worthy to be entrusted with the
dangerous secret." So Albert Pike, a
33rd degree Freemason, admits that the
Templars eventually became the
Freemasons. But who really controls the
Freemasons? In the book Freemasons
magazine and Masonic Mirror, volume
forward, this is from the 1800s, a
Masonic publication, it says on page
39, the brothers and fellows of the
Freemasons are the Scholastici and
Kodutors, spiritual as of the Jesuits.
For the temporal or secular Jesuits are
not yet members of the order. They are
not to do their own proper will. For the
order of the Jesuits requires absolute
obedience, and the secular Jesuits do
not yet know that Freemasonry is under
the direction of the order. The secrets
and secrecy of the masons allude to the
secrets of the Nostri or not. The valley
of Jehoshaphat even by its initial J
represents the Jesuits and symbolizes
the whole surface of the globe where the
masons are not to know that they are the
slaves of the Jesuits. By the way, they
certainly do not know it. The word
mosaic relating to pavement we are told
is written in italics to symbolize the
artifice of Moses who knew how to blind
the people of Israel to make them his
partisans. The blazing star is the sun,
the emblem of the order, the symbol of
omnipotence. The master mason represents
the chief of the notress or nostr and
refers to the general. The four
principles, the four vows of the
initiated Jesuits. So what this masonic
publication is saying is that the masons
fall directly under the Jesuits, but
that only on the absolute highest levels
the masons are aware of this. Now, in
his famous Total Onslaught series, Dr.
Waltervite shows some pictures of him
visiting a shrine. Pay attention to the
similar symbology between the Masons and
the
Templars. Now, let's go a little bit
into some of the history. I'm taking you
to this beautiful palace. Where do you
think it
is? It's in
Jerusalem and it's Natraan Vatican. And
this is where the Pope has his
representation in Jerusalem. It's a
palace for a king. There's the Vatican
flag flying outside. And here is the
Knight's Palace, the Latin Patriarch.
This is where the Knights Templars
originally had a sight. If you go
inside, there's this interesting altar.
And as you look at the altar, you'll see
certain figures over here. This one over
here is very interesting. Let me get a
little bit closer. And what do you see?
You see the double-headed eagle which is
also the symbol that is used in
Freemasonry. So there it is on the altar
of the knights and what is there on this
[Music]
side? Two swords held like a
compass. Fascinating. So there are many
many Masonic fig figures in here. the
tail feathers and the feathers of the
eagle. Very reminiscent of what you have
for example on the back of the dollar
and all those other interesting symbols
of the circle with the triangle and the
sun around it and uh the inheritor of
the
temper nuance are the Jesuits. Now the
Jesuits of
course are the ones who behind the
scenes control many things. Even Helena
Blavatsky, a highly influential
occultist and worshipper of Satan,
connects the Jesuits to the Knights
Templars.
So, Blavatsky said that the modern
versions of the Templars were actually
inspired and influenced by the Jesuits
to try to Christianize what the Templars
actually believe. And of course,
especially those flavors that are
connected with Freemasonry. It's not
just us making these connections. Let's
take a look again at Walterv's total
onslaught series as he shows you how the
Knights Templars, Jesuits, and
Freemasons are all basically the same
thing. Christianity and the secret
societies, we could summarize it as
follows. The old Babylonian religion
gave rise to
cabalism. via the scenes and others
nasticism came into existence
andnosticism was founded by Simon
Makers. This comes from no other source
than history of Lamagi and uh byas Levi.
Wow, that's a high Masonic source. So
nnasticism founded by Simon Maggas. Then
thisnosticism with its secret doctrine
was eventually over time through many
intermediary
organizations carried over to the
Knights Templars. And the Knights
Templars were a group
of a Roman Catholic order if you like
that were set over the temple site to
protect it. And they had strong links to
Islamic societies, the Ismiles, the
Karmatites, the Fatimites, the Duisers,
and the Assassins. Now, the Templars,
they had their secret inner information
inculcated in the Rossians and the
Jesuits. The Jesuits again formed and
created Freemasonry. And Freemasonry was
created as the Protestant arm of the
Roman Catholic Church, unbeknown to
them, beguiled, fooled, if you like,
into doing the work that Rome wanted
them to do so that Rome could sit in the
background while Freemasonry did it for
them. And then it wasn't them, it was
them. And it was mainly Protestants that
were doing it and not Rome. Very clever.
Very, very clever indeed. So you can see
how all this falls together. How
Jonathan Roomie is says he's a Knights
Templar, but then he also is really
flirting with the Freemason stuff. Um,
and then the Jesuits are like, "Well,
this stuff that the Freemason says is
theirs. It's like actually ours." But
really, if you look at the evidence,
it's all the same thing. It's all
intertwined and connected. The Knights
Templars even have the exact same cross
in their emblem as the Freemasons. And
they both have a crown and a sword. And
in fact, the Freemasons and Jesuits and
Knights Templars all have the same
references to the sun in their emblems.
Is that just coincidence? Let's let's
add another level to this layer. In an
interview, Jonathan Roomie reveals that
his father attended a Jesuit school.
My father's from the Middle East and the
family is Greek Orthodox and my mother's
Roman Catholic from
Ireland. And when we left New York City,
we we moved to the suburbs. There
weren't a whole lot of Orthodox churches
and my dad being a Christian in Egypt,
went to Catholic school run by French
Jesuits. Now, does attending a Jesuit
school automatically mean that you're a
devout Jesuit and somehow you're part of
a secret society? No. But when it comes
to Jonathan Roie though, we've already
seen some strong connections between him
and the Knights Templars and 33rd degree
Freemasons and
Jesuits. But as we continue, the
evidence just keeps stacking up.
Recently, Jonathan Rooney was kned into
yet another Catholic order, the Knights
of Columbus. Now, on their official
website, they state just a few months
before sharing his powerful prolife
message on the National Mall in
Washington DC, Roomie became a member of
the Knights of Columbus. So, they they
even visited him on the set of the
chosen where Roomie himself confirms
that he is uh a member of this
knighthood. T take a look at this clip.
I always wanted to be a Knight of
Columbus. They're awesome fellas. I'm
praying for them constantly and the
mission and the people that they serve.
My reaction as a knight is to be present
with them. That's kind of how I feel
like I can give back to the Knights.
When you look at the official emblem of
this order, you will see the Fasis
symbol. According to Britannica, the
word fascism comes from the Latin fascis
which denotes a bundle of wooden rods
that typically included a protruding ax
blade. In ancient Rome, licor's
attendance to the magistrates would hold
the fascis as a symbol of the penal
power of the magistrate. So this is how
Britannica describes fascism. To unify a
country, fascist movements propagated
extreme nationalism that often went
handinhand with militarism and racial
purity. The prosperity of a nation
depended on a unified polity that put
the group's welfare above the
individuals. A strong vigilant military
was considered necessary to defend these
group interests. Now, think about
Christian history. During the dark ages,
the Roman Catholic Church acted pretty
much the exact same way. Protestants,
people who dare to, you know, follow
their own conscience and they challenged
what they believe were unbiblical
teachings. They were hunted down. They
were tortured. They were killed by the
millions. And the goal of this this
persecution was to bring everybody under
the unity of Rome. Again, absolute
control with the pope at its head. No
room to have your own understanding of
scripture or your own conscience between
you and your God. Your own beliefs
according to what you believe scripture
says is true. It even used military
orders like the Knights of Malta, the
Knights of the Knights Templars and the
Jesuits to enforce this kind of control.
If you look at Pope Pius the 9th, he
once said, "The absurd and erroneous
doctrines in defense of liberty of
conscience are a most pestilential
error, a pest to be most dreaded in a
state." That doesn't sound like freedom
of religion. That sounds like fascism.
For today Rome considers the fascist
regime the nearest to its dogmas and
interest. We have not merely the
reverend Jesuit Father Cochland praising
Mussolini's Italy as a Christian
democracy but civil teala which is an
official mouthpiece of the Jesuits says
fascism is the regime that corresponds
most closely to the concept of the
church of Rome. So let me ask you this
question. Is it really coincidence that
the Knights of Columbus use a fascist
symbol? If this is in fact part of the
church's history and if this is in fact
according to the Jesuits this closely
aligned to the Catholic Church's beliefs
and Jonathan Roomie became a lifetime
knight of
[Music]
Columbus. The connections between the
Knights Templars and the Freemasons and
the Jesuits run really deep. But what do
these orders actually believe? Right? So
that we understand what does Jonathan
Roomie believe and what do these people
associated with the chosen who are
involved with this belief. For centuries
until 1798, the Roman Catholic Church
ruled the nations. kings were bowing
down before the pope and the Bible was
locked away in Latin which was not the
common language everybody read this era
the dark ages kept people from reading
God's word but then came the Protestant
reformation reformers like Martin Luther
John Kelvin and John Hus stood against
Rome exposing its errors in response
millions of Protestants were persecuted
and killed by the papacy
And that's where the Jesuits came in.
They were created to crush
Protestantism. They they operated in the
shadows working to bring the world back
under people control. And when sworn in,
they took an extremely
disturbing oath that shows that they
were actually absolutely the opposite of
biblical Christianity. This oath
resurfaced in the Library of Congress in
1912, bringing its dark nature to public
attention. Now, many claim that the oath
is a forgery, but there is actually
evidence that suggests otherwise. The
secret monita or the secret instructions
of the Jesuits was found hidden in
1596, decades before the supposed
forgery. Now, before I show you an
excerpt of from this oath, I want to
warn you that this this is pretty
gut-wrenching. But here's the oath. If
you want to pause this video, you read
it for yourself, you can. And I really
encourage you to do so to you and really
understand what the Jesuits are about.
So, as you can see, Jesuits have to
swear their own life and blood to
serving the Pope in secrecy with the aim
of destroying Protestantism. and and
then there's this whole slew of violent
and gory things they have to do to those
whom they consider heretics. Now, the
Knights Templars, they were founded in
1119 by Hugh the Payet and officially
recognized by the Catholic Church in
1129. They served the Pope by protecting
Christian pilgrims and waging war
against Rome's enemies. Now while the
Protestant Reformation hadn't begun yet,
their mission aligned with that of the
Jesuits we came later on. It was to
eliminate threats to papal authority.
They were known for their brutal
crusades. They targeted not just Muslims
but also groups deemed heretical by the
church. Though officially officially
this band in 1312, history suggests they
went underground later resurfacing as
Freemasons or other hidden Templars and
their legacy lived on, you know,
influencing both the Jesuits and the
Freemasons, two groups that would
continue to fight against Protestantism.
Lastly, let's look at the Freemasons. In
this book by Albert Pike, Morals and
Dogma on page 321, it shows you exactly
who they worship. Lucifer, the
lightbearer. Strange and mysterious name
given to the spirit of darkness.
Lucifer, the son of the morning. It is
he who brings the light, he who bears
the light, and with splendor intolerable
blinds feeble, sensual, and selfish
souls. Doubt it not.
[Applause]
[Music]
You have probably seen an ad for Hallow,
the Catholic prayer and meditation app
featuring Jonathan Roomie as he invites
you to pray with him. Hey, I know you're
in the middle of something, but I wonder
if you just take a few seconds to pray
with me real quick. In the name of the
Father, Son, Holy Spirit. Amen. Seems
harmless, right? But is it just an app
encouraging prayer? Let's take a closer
look as things get really interesting.
Many of the prayers in Hallow trace
directly back to Ignatius of Lyola,
again the founder of the Jesuits. And
Roomie isn't just a face of the app.
He's actually leading users through
Ignatian prayers, guiding them into
Jesuit spiritual exercises with his own
voice. Hallow openly promotes
contemplative prayer, a practice rooted
in Ignatius teachings. Now, while it
claims to bring people close to God,
it's actually doing the exact opposite.
Take a look at what Stephanie Griffin
says. She used to be a Christian mystic
and practiced these types of prayers,
including contemplative prayer, which is
ignation spirituality. But now she came
out of that and she actually warns other
Christians against it.
Stephanie, give me a definition of
mindless mindfulness meditation. What is
that? Well, meditation simply has to do
with emptying your mind in terms of what
the app wants you to do and what we
learned in contemplative prayer. So, you
empty your mind, you get everything out
of the way, nothing between you and God
so that you can hear the voice of God.
So, the intention is really pure. So,
for those who don't understand
contemplative prayer, maybe this is
their first time of hearing anything
about it. We have a couple quotes. One
is from Richard Foster who wrote
celebration of discipline. He says that
meditation is a good way to obtain a
consistent alpha brain wave pattern. So,
we're looking at an alpha brain wave.
You and I are in beta right now. We're
thinking, we're discerning. We're like,
this stuff is, you know, why why I'm
thinking, why did I do this for so long?
How did I not see? This is discernment,
right? We can we can think and judge
critically. In alpha, it's a it's a
hypnotic state. I'm alert. I know what's
going on, but my frontal lobe is shut
down. MRI studies show that um there's
decreased blood flow in the frontal lobe
when you're an alpha. They say in here
it turns you to God. But when you empty
your mind and you go into alpha wave,
you shut down your frontal lobe. The
very place where the Holy Spirit can
speak to you, convict you, give you
discernment. So it's going to be another
voice we're going to hear. So
contemplative prayer, a core Jesuit
practice, is one of the prayers Jonathan
Roomie personally guides users through
in Hallow. It it's a it's a prayer he
actively practices
himself. But Jonathan Roomie isn't alone
in this. The the app also features big
names like Mark Wahlberg, the actor,
Father Mike Schmidz that we talked about
earlier, who together with Jonathan
Rooney led a Lenton prayer series
together based on a book by no other
than a Jesuit priest, Walter Cisak. This
effort was publicly announced on no
other than the Jesuits USA East website.
And another key figure that we see a lot
in Hallow is Timothy Gallagher. He's a
well-known author and speaker
specializing in ignation, discernment,
and prayer. And he wrote eight books on
the topic. So, his involvement only
reinforces Hallow's deep Jesuit
influence. And if that wasn't enough,
the app's board of adviserss, it
includes at least three individuals,
including again Mike Schmidtz, who
either have strong ties to the Jesuits
or actively promote Ignatian
spirituality. So with Jonathan Room
being the face of the app, it's clear
how isn't just a prayer app. It's a
platform for pushing Jesuit teachings.
Now if you want a deeper dive into
Hallow and Room's connections, we have a
video about that on our YouTube channel.
You can check the link in the
description
below. Now, here is an absolute
bombshell. On March 5th, 2025, Tucker
Carlson released a lengthy interview
with Jonathan Roomie ahead of the chosen
season 5 release date. And in it, Roomie
made a absolute shocking statement.
Ignatian spirituality is the very
foundation of the
show. So, fast forward 6 months later, I
get this audition for The Two Thieves. I
didn't get the the penitent thief. I go
and I audition for Jesus because I'm
like, you know what? I enjoyed playing
Jesus six months ago, like this would be
cool. If I got if I got anything, it
would be cool because I wasn't working
steadily
consistently. And the way Dallas tells
the story about 10 seconds into the
audition, he's like, "That's Jesus.
That's my Jesus for this show." And so
we did that film and it was screened. He
brought me back to to view it like a
month later at the Good Friday service
with his church about seven services. It
was like 15,000 people saw this thing in
a matter of a day and a half and it was
remarkably wellreceived. It was so
beautiful and it was it was the
essentially the the foundational bones
of the concept of the chosen which is
this um this sort of ignatian
spirituality. designation uh insight
into uh the gospels which is basically
you put yourself in the gospel you ask
in the gospels you ask yourself a series
of questions and that's how you meditate
on the gospels through this form of
spirituality and so this this process of
filmm was kind of like a a living
example of that on on celluloid or
digital celluloid but this wasn't the
first time that he said this I found a
clip back in 2023 where Rooney sat sat
down with Bishop Robert Baron. Remember
him? The Catholic leader deeply
influenced by Jesuit theologians Carl
Roner Pierard Chardin. In that
interview, they both affirm the
connection between the chosen and
Ignatian spirituality.
[Music]
Well, just an observation about biblical
literature, both Old Testament and New
is very laconic. It's very understated.
Typically the biblical authors in a few
little deaf strokes will sketch a
character. Uh you don't get a hundred
pages of psychological elaboration the
way you get like in a great you know
contemporary novelist. But what's
happened as a result of that is the
whole midrashic tradition emerged first
in Judaism which is a sort of narrative
and imaginative elaboration of the
biblical text. So the Bible will say
Abraham goes up the mountain with Isaac,
you know, well, I mean, what's going on
at that moment in the mind and heart of
Abraham? Well, the midrashic tradition
loves to elaborate that. And I would say
some of the elements within the chosen
are kind of like that. It the the Bible
sketches it very and it's it's part of
the beauty of biblical narrative that
it's done in this almost modernist way
that's very understated. Um but then
artists have always loved think of the
way painters do it. Dramatists have done
it. The midrashic tradition has done it
is they've imaginatively elaborated upon
the biblical text. So I would put the
chosen and its writers kind of in that
tradition. I don't think it violates in
any way the integrity of the Bible or
you know runs counter to it. I think as
Catholics we can just point to Ignatius.
I mean, it's like the Ignatian
tradition. Like, imagine what it would
be like to be in this scene with Jesus
and the disciples. And and we do, and we
write it on paper, then we go film it.
The screenplay writers and director
Dallas Jenkins work closely with three
key religious consultants. They're
Messianic Rabbi Jason Soil, uh,
Evangelical Professor Dr. Doug Huffman
and Catholic priest and national
director of family theater productions,
Father David Guffy. Now, among them,
Father David Guffy stands out for his
deep Jesuit ties. On his Facebook page,
he openly shares that he attended a
Jesuit university for film and
television production and he also
studied theology at Notre Dame. Now,
while this is not a Jesuit school in
particular, it does heavily promote
Ignatian spirituality. Look at this for
example. I have in front of
me a course outline, Ignatian
spirituality, an introduction, and it
outlines what students will go through
at Notre Dame as they take this class to
learn how to do contemplative prayer um
and other uh spiritual practices that
the founder of the Jesuits, Ignatius of
Leola, taught. And then there's this
other thing here. This is a university
publication where it says the Ignatian
spiritual journey. They're promoting
Ignatian spiritual practices. They're
offering courses. They're hosting Jesuit
scholars. They're featuring Jesuit
theology in in their publications. These
three consultants for the chosen
directly shape the chosen script. If
they disagree with a certain element,
they can push for that change and their
voices could be heard to the point where
the script is adjusted. And one of them,
Father Guffy, is deeply rooted in Jesuit
practices himself. Listen to what he
says about the chosen and Ignatian
spirituality.
It seemed from the conversations that it
might have been a little bit more
difficult when you had to fill in the
gaps that scripture doesn't talk about.
Scripture doesn't talk about what the
scene looked like. It doesn't talk about
who else was in the crowd. It doesn't
talk about what they were wearing. So
that takes some imagination. But we have
a tradition of that in the Catholic
Church. St. Ignatius of Loyola, the
founder of the Jesuits, he especially
urged his followers and even today to
take a piece of scripture, read it
closely, get a sense of the place, get a
sense of the story. What did it look
like? What did it sound like? and that
it invites the the person who's praying
to put themselves in the scene. Going
even further back, in the very first
round table discussion that Dallas
Jenkins ever hosted with his three
religious adviserss, Father Guffy again
emphasized the connection between the
chosen and Ignatian spirituality.
One of the ways that Catholics pray with
scripture, and this came from St. S. and
Ignatius of Loyola is to read scripture
and read it a couple of times and then
to engage it with imagination and to
really sit in meditative state and put
try to put yourself in the scene so that
you can imagine the characters and the
ignation style of meditation would
invite one to listen imagine what you
what you'd hear, what you'd taste, what
you'd smell, what you'd touch and this
seemed almost like that kind of a
meditation on scripture and looking at
the world that people would be And when
you do that kind of meditation, you have
to do it with some humility that you're
not actually having a vision because
there's interpretation going on. And we
obviously bring a 21st century mindset
and references to it. And I thought the
series did some of the same. It's in
English that's easily accessible today
with patterns of speech that are
probably closer to today, but that is an
imagining of what of who these people
might have been and what their world
would have been like. The other thing
that I found fascinating is Mary
Magdalene is such an interesting
character and before the 1600s, Mary
Magdalene was featured prominently in in
art in European cathedrals. Um that
changed somewhat with the Reformation
for a lot of different reasons, but she
was really a powerful figure in the
imagination of of
Catholics for about 600 years. lots of
images of her and I thought of there's a
window at the cathedral at chart um
that's a Mary Magdalene window that
essentially imagines the story of Mary
Magdalene and the way that the episode
one does kind of going through the life
of Mary Magdalene. So, uh, I I when I
when I read the script and, um, and
became aware of episode one, I I
immediately thought of that window and I
thought, "Oh, they're doing what they
did in the 1200s when they built the
cathedral at Chart." The Shartz
Cathedral that Father Guthrie referenced
was built in honor of the Virgin Mary,
who in Catholic tradition is considered
a prime example of contemplated prayer.
But what's what's even more concerning
is that inside this cathedral there's a
labyrinth specifically designed for
Catholics to walk while engaging in
contemplative prayer. Labyrinth have
deeply occult origins. It dates back to
ancient pagan religions. And yet this
cathedral with its devotion to the
Catholic version of Mary, this cathedral
that is drenched in Ignatian
spirituality is what comes to Guffy's
mind when he is reflecting on the
chosen's first episode of season 1. And
this isn't just his interpretation. On
the website of America, the Jesuit
review, another direct connection is
made between the chosen and Jesuit
contemplative prayer.
On Jonathan Roomy's website, the
quintessential Jesus.com, he openly
states that he is a method actor. But
what many don't realize is that method
acting has deep ties to dark
spirituality, even going as far as
demonic possession. Now, we're not
saying that every method actor is
possessed, but the technique itself is
built around allowing yourself to get
emptied or emptying yourself and having
something else take over. So, is that
biblical? Should a Christian ever
surrender their mind this way? The Bible
gives clear warning in Matthew 12:44-45.
Then he says, "I will return to my house
from which I came." And when he comes,
he finds it empty, swept, and put in
order. Then he goes and takes with him
seven other spirits more wicked than
himself. And they enter and dwell there.
And the last state of that man is worse
than the first. So the real question is,
when you empty yourself, what or who are
you letting in?
I've been told that um all actors really
hail from the early medicine men and the
the shamans in the villages
pre-Christianity where they would put on
masks and and act out and and really
what they were probably pretty crazy but
they would go in and find answers to
questions. Today you're called psychotic
if you do that but it's all it's all uh
semantics. So, what I would do is I put
on AfroCaribbean paint, like a white and
black paint, and black out my eyes so I
look like this sort of AfroCaribbean
voodoo icon. And then I would sew in
bits of u Egyptian artifacts that were
thousands of years old into my costume
and gather some onyx or termine or
something that was meant to have
vibrations. And who knows if it works or
doesn't, but for me it was an idea of
like trying to stimulate my my mind or
trick my mind into believing I was this
this character from another dimension.
And I would walk on the set and then
wouldn't speak to anybody, wouldn't say
a word. So I projected this aura of
horror which created fear in my fellow
actors which then inspired me to believe
I really was this character. I try to
allow the spirit of the character to
live through me. So I just try to
encompass and allow myself I'm almost
the vehicle to channel the spirit of the
character through. Screw award-winning
actor Denzel Washington told 60 Minutes
exactly how he brings forth his best
performances. Basically what I did was
got on my
knees and sort of communicated with the
spirits and when I came out I was in
charge. Powerful scene. Powerful scene.
It it I couldn't have acted that. I
couldn't have written that down and made
a decision to play that. The one woman
entertainment empire known as Oprah has
strong affiliations with the demonic
realm. The most familiar face on
television says, "You cannot only use
your body and physical self. This is how
I see acting. I ask my body to be the
carrier for the spirits of those who
have come before me in a way that is
most meaningful to the character. Just
become the vehicle for that character."
We were talking about mystery earlier
and how the and the process of absorbing
Desmond's essence and attempting to
ingest him. So I so I stay in the accent
all the time to not confuse myself
mostly. So I mean I his talents I think
I think very talented just suited this
character and then I wasn't disappointed
at all. He's managed to inhabit Desmond
or Desmond inhabited him. I'm not sure
which. I think there was some both going
on. that there was a a particularly
profound moment where I went to um
Chattanooga, Tennessee, which is where
Desmond eventually retired and passed
away. And I went onto his old property
um and went into his his old wood
woodshed and handled his tools and
walked around the lake that he would
walk around. And it was I spent a day
there just kind of praying and and and
asking like just guide me through this.
If you can hear me, tell like tell me
tell me what to do. Tell me how to move,
tell me how to speak, tell me how to
behave, and I'll do whatever you say. So
that there was some there there was a a
strange mysterious
spirituality going on around the the
making of this film. Consider actor
Andrew Garfield. He played the Jesuit
priest in movie Silence. And in an
interview on the late night show with
Steven Colbear, he revealed that he
spent an entire year studying under no
other than a Jesuit priest, Father James
Martin. Now listen closely to what he
says about what he learned from him. You
have to study like did you study to be a
Jesuit? I studied with a mutual friend
of ours, Father James Martin, who he was
the chaplain of the Coburn Nation. Yeah.
And someone that I love as dearly as you
seem to. and he um I studied with him
for a year and I went through the um
Ignatian spiritual exercises and you
know you know uh not only did we study
the theology and the the history of the
society of Jesus um but there's these
these processes called the spiritual
exercises that St. Ignatius created when
he founded the order. Um, and it's this
transformational process where you do
these imaginative meditative prayers
with um, the life of Jesus where you
place yourself in each scene much like
being an actor. And actually I found out
that Stannislavski who invented modern
acting, the method of modern acting that
resulted in the American method and
everything after that was deeply
inspired by St. Ignatius's spiritual
exercises. So I felt kind of right at
home. And remember Jonathan Roomie
openly identifies as a method actor.
Now, can can we say with certainty that
he is possessed while portraying Jesus
as the chosen? No. No, we we can't. But,
you know, given the nature of both
method acting, which he does, and
contemplative prayer, which he
practices, that both asks you to empty
yourself and let something else in. The
implications should deeply concern any
Bible believing Christian.
The connection between method acting and
ignation spirituality is not accidental.
The Jesuits have influenced Hollywood
and the film industry since its very
inception. Check out this this document
this essay uh this scholastic essay I
should say written by Henry Schnitzler.
He is uh a member of the department of
theater arts at
UCLA and this was actually um published
by John Hopkins and he talks about a
Jesuit priest called Anastasia Kercher
who invented the magic lantern which was
the first device to project images. Um
Kercher student another Jesuit Gaspar
Shot documented these advancements which
later paved the way for motion pictures
which is what our whole movie industry
is based on. Another Jesuit Cloud
Francis Miller Chalet discovered that
the human eye perceives light color
rather than objects in motion which was
a foundational principle of film making.
But why would the Jesuits, a religious
order, invest so much in visual
storytelling? According to Encyclopedia
Britannica, Jesuit theater was
specifically designed, not surprising,
to counter the Protestant Reformation.
And and we see this as well in in this
academic article that Henry Schnitler
wrote for the John Hopkins University
Press. He writes about the educational
system the Jesuits created. How they had
become the school masters of Europe.
Their education was to serve as a
fighting force in the struggle against
the new faith, meaning the Protestant
Reformation. Jesuit's performance was to
be an irresistible appeal to the senses
and emotions rather than to the
intellect and reason. A spectator was to
be virtually hypnotized by a concerted
attack of all known theatrical devices
until he surrendered his entire being to
the drama's spiritual message. They
shrewly disguised it under a colorful
cloak of splendid entertainment. There
was not a single theatrical genre that
could not at some time or place be seen
in a Jesuit theater. E even if those
genres were not even closely religious,
these genres were admitted to the Jesuit
schools only as long as they could be
made to serve the orders, listen to
this, neverchanging aim. The Jesuits saw
the theater as a powerful weapon for the
implementation of counterreformatory
propaganda. So it created the Jesuit
school theater. It was in every way a
propaganda theater used for
propagandistic ends. These were
naturally more conspicuous during the
first decades of the order's existence
when new ground had to be won chiefly by
reaching huge audiences and impressing
them with the spiritual message of Roman
Catholicism. So, so let's fast forward
to today. The entertainment industry
operates in really much the same way.
It's appealing to the emotions and
senses using Hollywood as a vehicle to
relay a message and change society. Um,
so I I always like to think of it as
like I've got them sitting there. Whip a
little message at them. Whip a little
moral at them. Whip a little of what my
view of the world is cuz that's what
every good filmmaker does. But are the
Jesuits still involved in Hollywood?
Now, absolutely. This clip from Jesuits
in America, a documentary, explains
more. link in the description to get
yourself a copy of this documentary.
Some believe that Hollywood movies are
really a modern version of what was
known as Jesuit theater in centuries
past, where the order communicated ideas
through dramatic plays.
The book Jesuit Hollywood by Shaun
Wilcock documents how Jesuits use
theater as part of the
counterreformation to refute the
anti-apist dramas inspired by Martin
Luther. Wilcock writes that the Jesuits
saw the theater as having a very great
purpose in their schemes to promote
Jesuit religious propaganda to the
masses.
[Music]
Far from being a minor instrument for
teaching, the Jesuits incorporated the
use of dramas, dance, and opera in their
schools and missions around the
world. In the 20th century, they were
even responsible for creating the
official production code for making
movies in
Hollywood. Also called the Hayes Code
after Congressman William Hayes, it was
originally intended to prevent immoral
practices from being communicated on
film. The code was developed by Catholic
publisher Martin Quigley along with a
Jesuit priest named the Reverend Daniel
Lord.
The code was upheld for some 20 years by
a Jesuit educated Catholic named Joseph
Breen who became the central figure
associated with the moral boundaries
imposed on the film
industry. At one point, Breen was even
said to have more influence over world
opinion than Hitler, Mussolini or Stalin
because of the tremendous power he had
over the content of Hollywood
movies. Okay, so let's bring it back to
the chosen. Remember that interview
between Bishop Baron and Jonathan Roomie
that we showed you earlier? In that same
conversation, Bishop Baron is discussing
the painter Carvajio. So Caravajjo lived
during the time of the Protestant
Reformation and he actually was using
his paintings as a way to counter the
Protestant Reformation. He was hired by
Jesuits at times to do that work and
turn people back to Catholicism. In this
interview, Bishop Baron uses Carvajio,
that painter, as an example for how the
Catholic film and TV industry works
today in order to evangelize for their
faith. And the context of all of this is
of course the chosen.
Let's talk a little bit about the role
of the arts in general in
evangelization. Um you you you talked
about how how important the video or
visual uh media medium is. Um I'm
wondering what you bishop are hearing
about the chosen in convers. It's got to
be part of the conversation now that
you're hearing a lot more about. in
general the role of the arts in
evangelization and and you talked about
that at some length last night but yeah
I as I say that's that's essential to
the Catholic tradition that we use the
visual and you know the the gift of of
something like cinema there's a picture
like a caravajio is of enormous power
but gosh you put Carvajio in motion and
you put Carvajio with speech and you put
Carvajio with all the dramatic
possibilities of a film that's why
they're so rich that's why a film or the
TV production will stay in our minds and
so it is yes a vehicle for
evangelization you know I've been
harping for years now on the rise of the
nuns you know the the disaffiliation
from the church our young people all
that's true and it's a it's a summons to
all of us to evangelize every way we can
see I'm sensitive to the way the Holy
Spirit moves and the Holy Spirit raises
up you know institutions and
organizations and individuals and raises
up something like the chosen I
as a vehicle for evangelizing,
especially young people. So, just be
mindful of the Holy Spirit. He's always
operative, always, you know, signs of
life all over. And I think The Chosen is
definitely one of those. Did you just
hear that? He said that there is
enormous power in cinema. You put
Carvado Joe in motion and speech with
all the dramatic possibilities of a
film. That's why a film or TV production
will stay in your minds. So he is
talking about putting Carvajio this
painter that lived during the time of
the reformation that was used hired by
the Jesuits to create artwork to destroy
the Protestant faith. That painter Carva
Joe is who Bishop Baron uses in context
of the Catholic film and TV industry.
This form of art is an evangelization
tool just like the chosen.
Millions of Protestants watch The
Chosen, a show that has captivated
Christian audiences worldwide. I mean, I
used to watch it too. I was a huge fan.
I loved the storytelling, the
characters, the cinematography.
But as I start digging deeper, I had to
ask myself, if there's so many direct
connections between the chosen and the
Jesuits and the Freemasons and the
Knights Templars, then what's the real
agenda? And then we haven't even talked
about the things we discussed in the
first documentary we made about the
chosen yet. I mean, there's so much more
to it. You know, I think you have to
really ask yourself this question of why
would there be so many links between a
show about Jesus and secret
organizations that have a long well well
doumented history of infiltrating and
undermining Protestantism, including
fighting against our Jesus. Don't forget
Jonathan Roomie admitted himself to
being a Knights Templar which is on par
with the 33rd degree Freemason. And
remember that Freemasons at the higher
levels
admit admit to worshiping Satan. In
Revelation 13, the Bible describes two
beast powers uniting with the dragon,
the biblical symbol of Satan to bring
about great deception in the last days.
And their aim is to enforce the mark of
the beast so that all the world wanders
after the beast and worships it, not
God. It's a false counterfeit system of
worship. Those who do not receive this
mark of the beast, which is synonymous,
by the way, for the Antichrist, will be
persecuted, cannot buy or sell, and will
even be killed. When we study the books
of Daniel and Revelation, looking at the
fulfillment of prophecy in history and
today, there is only one entity that
fits the biblical description of the
Antichrist or beast power entirely, and
that's the papacy of the Roman Catholic
Church. This is not, absolutely not an
attack on individual Catholics, many of
whom love Jesus, and they're earnestly
seeking for the truth. I know this
personally because I was part of the
system once. I was baptized into the
Catholic church as a baby. I went
through the classes for my first
communion. I attended Eucharist services
and even owned a rosary. But later I
became a Protestant and that's when I
discovered the truth of scripture. So
last scriptura, the Bible and the Bible
alone. The antichrist power we are
referring to is not Pope Francis as an
individual, but rather the system of the
papacy itself, a system that has worked
for centuries to counter God's truth and
bring the world under its authority
under a cloak or a guise of
Christianity. So why would
Satan create a darkl looking entity if
he can make a counterfeit Christianity
and deceive the whole world with it?
Just like the Jesuits on the outside
look good, serving other people,
visiting hospitals, doing all these
things, but all with the purpose that
they were made for to to counter the
reformation. A quick side note here. If
you've heard of theories that the
Antichrist was only in the past or that
he hasn't appeared yet, he's not here
right now and he will only come in the
future, you should probably know that
these ideas were actually created by the
Jesuits, not surprising, to take the
heat off of the Catholic Church during
the time of the Reformation because so
many reformers were publicly saying the
papacy was the antichrist. It's just
somehow this has been we've forgotten
about it today. But this is the truth.
We put together a verse byvere study,
like two videos on what the antichrist
is, what the mark of the beast is, and
we even have a video on our channel
explaining the origins of 666 and what
that actually means. Link in the
description.
So, could it be that The Chosen is part
of a larger effort to reshape
Christianity, to reshape your
understanding of Jesus that suddenly
pulls Protestants back into Romanism?
maybe if they're from a different uh you
know denomination to kind of see that um
how how uh ecumenical this movement was
uh because it affected so many different
kinds of Christians and then we haven't
even discussed the ecumenical efforts of
Jonathan Roomie yet that he does outside
of the chosen again turning soles
scriptor Protestants back to
Catholicism in other words a show like
the chosen may not be overtly im
immoral. It's not immoral. But if it is
spiritually misleading, then it is just
as dangerous to your eternal salvation.
If you want to dig deeper into this top
these topics, I highly recommend The
Great Controversy, a book that lays out
the works of the Jesuits, the role of
the papacy in Bible prophecy, and the
battle between good truth and deception.
You can find a link in the description
for a free copy if you're interested.
Definitely worthwhile. Also check out
the documentary Revelation: The Bride,
the Beast in Babylon, which uncovers the
truth about end time prophecy in a
powerful powerful way, and it's free on
YouTube. Link in the description. At the
end of the day, I I had a decision to
make. I had to make a choice. Do I keep
watching this show because it feels
good? Because it
emotionally moves me? because I love I
love the way Jesus was portrayed and I
wanted him to be the real biblical
Jesus.
Or do I seek the real Jesus as he is
revealed in scripture, untainted by
human interpretation, untouched by
secret societies that seek to destroy my
faith in my redeemer. You have the same
choice. But as we've said before, I can
assure you the book is better.
[Music]
[Applause]